hey there it's Wonder Mike I've come to
say hello you know I am your hip hop pop
music maven
[Music]
I'm on a channel I don't really know
anything about this song they've just
told me they said Michael you're
probably not gonna like this song but it
is really popular right now so you have
to listen to it the song is Miley Cyrus
this is a breakup Anthem called flowers
which she apparently released on her
ex-husband Liam Hemsworth's birthday
Miley take it away
[Music]
we were good
kind of dream that can't be sold
we were right
[Music]
built a home and watched it burn
um
[Music]
foreign
like
devastating I kind of like Miley I'm
going to put my cards on the table I'm
learning a lot about myself through this
music series I didn't realize I was a
Swifty or a Belieber and I'm a Miley
man to I don't know what Miley's fans
are called because I love that song
Party in the USA I really got a kick out
of it when it came out I remember Miley
Cyrus was married I didn't realize she
got divorced but I I just remember for
all of her crazy eccentric show busy
stuff she seemed to have a kind of
conservatism to her in that she got
married in that she I think she's
Southern right I think she talked about
partying in the USA vaguely patriotic
and in this song she's saying we had
this great house we had this great home
I didn't want to leave it I did you
basically you screwed it all up I didn't
want to mess up our marriage and now
what now what does she say
I can take myself dancing I can hold my
own hand I can write my name in the sand
I can I can tell me I love me I can
always I can do all the stuff that a
husband is supposed to do better than
you can and I can do it all alone and I
assume this is the point of the song is
that it certainly seems like the the
lady doth protests too much me thinks
that you can't really do that you can be
very hurt if someone leaves you and you
can say well screw you I don't need you
I'll I'll just be my own spouse I'll buy
myself the presents I'll take myself out
on dates I'll take my I'll write my own
name in the sand but I don't need you
but that comes from a place of hurt
she's walking through the song wearing
this kind of embittered looking outfit
lamenting her ex-husband yeah she's
telling you there she goes yeah fine
I'll do all this stuff but I'm not going
to be happy about it I'm going to resent
it as well she should
Rose
[Music]
I can buy myself flowers
[Applause]
[Music]
it might be true it might be true that
she can love her better than he can but
that's a real knock on him Showbiz
people get divorced all the time and
Miley Cyrus she's got a ton of money and
she's been famous since she was she was
very little and she's got everything in
the world right why would she be upset
well because life is about more than
money and because life is about more
than Fame and you can have all the
personal servants in the world and
you've got all the workout classes you
can even see her moving around and you
know she obviously still works out she
still looks looks good but we still feel
sad for this character we still feel sad
for this person who's there and saying
yeah I don't need a husband I don't need
someone to love me I don't need no
that's okay I'll just I'm gonna work out
and do it myself and I can love me
better than you can maybe that's true
but it's not supposed to be that way
we're supposed to we're supposed to love
our spouses and stick by our spouses and
she's I didn't want to fight I didn't
want to leave I don't know why you you
did this basically and I that's fine
I'll move on but I'm I'm still
embittered by it as she should be
[Music]
all right
started to cry but then Modern Art is so
ugly
it's kind of a side side piece but
there's like statues and
that cold clinical looking house
[Applause]
sure I'm sure the house costs millions
and millions of dollars but look how
cold it is look how clinical it has no
ornamentation
much like the life that she's describing
it's just all totally
clean with any attachments
and so she dances around like she's 23
years old
but but she's recognizing that she's not
23 years old but life has progressed
since then she's been married and she's
trying to to go back but one cannot do
that
[Music]
life is supposed to progress
and we're supposed to gain more
attachments and more ornamentation and
allow that to augment our lives and what
happens in modernity is we don't get
married and stay married we just we have
a relationship for a period and then we
have a sort of mutual decoupling and
then we just then we just go back to
square one we just forget that we're
living in time and space we try to deny
that we're living in time and space we
have everything be totally clean and
clinical and okay and now that marriage
and phase is over that's okay I'll love
me better than you can and I'm just
going to go back to dancing like I did
when I was a kid and I'll have another
relationship and another cold clinical
kind of sterile neutral playing round
then we'll just allow that cycle to
repeat all the while one seems to get a
little less joyful and a little a little
more resentful about the whole thing all
right that's Miley Monday Miley Monday
for you here's Michael from Miley Monday
saying see you tomorrow
[Applause]
foreign